as expected london the capital will move
to tier three
i'm told by two mps who are on that call
that will happen
from one minute past midnight on
wednesday so
in what a day or so time so
not straight away tomorrow i guess will
be
still in tier two but after one minute
past midnight on wednesday that will be
london into tier three which of course
means for hospitality
all of hospitality having to close and
move to take away only it also means in
terms of our social interactions
with each other it will mean that people
are not able to mix in private gardens
not able to mix in pub
gardens and restaurant outdoor areas
either so
a real blow to hospitality in the run-up
to the christmas
period uh we heard earlier from the
mayor of london saying that
um he wasn't calling for um tier three
in london because he felt that there
needed to be more economic help more
financial support
for businesses in the run-up to
christmas who are probably hoping to try
and recoup some of the losses
from the last six or seven months but it
does appear that that is what's going to
happen three mps saying that london is
going into tier three
two who are on that call saying it will
be from midnight um on
wednesday matt hancock is due in the
commons um at 3 30 he's then due to host
a press conference from downing street
where we should get
specific confirmation of that from the
health secretary i think there will be
questions
um about whether more measures need to
be brought in on top of the basic tier
three measures we see what's been going
on
um in kent as well that's been in tier
three
but cases have seemed stubbornly high
there there are also reports of other
places
around the exteriors of london other
counties in the home counties also
moving to
no confirmation yet of that though